[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la liste d'union locale que je porte
avec mustapha larbaoui c'est une vraie
liste de rassemblement
je sais que certains veulent faire de
cette élection un débat uniquement entre
la droite et la gauche sauf que nous on
a construit quelque chose qui n'est pas
très très largement le clivage droite
gauche vote des gens de toutes
sensibilités mustapha larbaoui et du
sens et des politiques qui n'est pas la
mienne
et pourtant vous sommes réunis avec un
vrai projet sur les dossiers parce qu'en
réalité on la face à nos deux candidats
issus de la majorité sortante d'une
majorité qui se déchire
ils ont tous les deux été aux
responsabilités et qu'ils ont tous les
deux ans les chèques par un certain
nombre de sujets par exemple à l'arrêt
de la bétonisation de trappes qui s'est
énormément densifie dernières années je
suis le seul candidat à avoir voté
contre les opérations de promotion
immobilière partout dans la ville selon
sans que l'on n'ait plus aucun espace
vert aucun espace de stationnement et il
est aujourd'hui l'un contient de plus en
plus difficile je pense aux services de
proximité le tout n'est pas uniquement
d'avoir des beaux slogans à la bouche
mais en matière de santé il a fallu que
ce soit la région
à ma demande qui viennent financer le
cabinet médical qui est ouvert aux
murisier et nous aurons demain un
cabinet médical maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire du même type au
quartier jaurès où il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui aucun médecin généraliste
je pense à la fiscalité là aussi manière
très concrète pendant la deuxième taxe
foncière la plus élevée des yvelines
nous l'avait second elle a augmenté de
10% la trappe en 2015 mes deux
adversaires ont goûté main dans la main
cette augmentation
naturellement nous reviendrons à un
niveau beaucoup plus convenable vous le
voyez à chaque fois sur des sujets très
très concret très pratique nous avons un
projet cohérent et constant dans le
temps et la capacité de mettre en oeuvre
et de finance
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelque chose que vous ferons
ensemble je crois c'est relancer la
concertation avec les craintes la
concertation d'abord sur les codes venez
nous reviendrons à la semaine de quatre
jours mais tout cela s'organise et nous
voulons le faire dans le dialogue avec
la communauté éducative les parents
d'élèves et les enseignants c'est un
dialogue qui a beaucoup manqué à trappes
ces dernières années il est bien sûr la
concertation c'est tout c'est que le
comité de quartier ces derniers grands
projets de rénovation qui reste ans à
camus je prends ça c'est une nouvelle à
barbusse je pense à malindi ce qu'elle
est il ya encore beaucoup d'aménagements
à faire pour améliorer réellement la
calcule reprendre le dialogue avec les
trappistes dans l'apaisement dans la
sérénité et aussi surtout quand le
rassemblement aujourd'hui on a besoin de
tout le monde pour faire réussir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]